who's up next hi I'm Andrew all right
what do you do I'm a headhunter a
headhunter it sounds exciting people say
that and then you remember how boring it
is off you go with your story okay so my
fiancee is from the Czech Republic and a
big big tradition there on Easter Monday
and this is fact is the the girl's big
to get whipped
okay I gotta where we got these people
from were they vetted in his line it is
like we left the door open over the week
people just wandered in okay next one
please hello what's your name
Petra Petra and were you from Petra I'm
from Czech Republic
[Applause]
just like happy Easter gosh you can sit
down
it's true it's true we beggin to be
whipped no no youyou don't beg to be
whipped you betcha I don't a Monday only
on Easter bunny small is a tradition
that you get whipped on Easter Monday
you were remained beautiful and healthy
for the upcoming year
[Laughter]
or maybe she thought maybe she thought
then I'll get it out of the way in the
one-day instr Tuesday suppose do you
have a story or he deserted oh you do
have a story off you go off you go yeah
so about three years ago my fiance and I
we went to Paris for a romantic weekend
and at the hotel I realized I don't have
a toothbrush so I decided to pop into
the pharmacy while he was waiting
outside so I walked back out and I said
well you would be surprised but French
people actually I really know it's
impolite and he said well how come and I
said well if you show a bit of effort
and speak a little bit of French instead
of English they really appreciate it and
he said so what did you say and I said
well I walk in I said Bonjour Monsieur
she would lay and
[Applause]
[Music]
my basic baby you know what
[Laughter]
rewind hair Bravo Figaro ba ba ba ba ma
ba Bravo Figaro bava bava Simo